[Music]
at the Seas with Nemo and friends at
Epcot new faces appear every day
but old friends are never far away like
guest favorite
Lil Joe
this guy was found alone in the wild as
a baby but the team took him in and gave
him the chance to flourish
I love Joe the manatee he is one of my
favorites
Joe is very charismatic I think he's
very handsome his face is adorable he's
pretty easy going
what is not to love about Joe
[Music]
but recently there's been a problem
despite his name Lil Joe shouldn't be so
Lil
Joe's weight is under where we would
like it to be so that's concerning for
me
yesterday he ate about 30 heads of
lettuce and usually he would eat 90. we
want to be able to help him and we can't
help him if we don't know what's wrong
if only manatees could communicate with
humans
Well turns out this clever guy kinda can
[Music]
Little Joe started taking both of his
pectoral flippers and putting them in
his mouth and kind of chewing on them
sometimes what that behavior tells us is
he may be uncomfortable in his mouth
[Music]
time for some Manatee dentistry and at
this dentist head protection is a must
Joe may be underweight but that huge
tail still packs a punch first I'm gonna
put these under his head
an x-ray May reveal anything unusual
with Joe's mouth
[Music]
this yeah
something doesn't look right
that looks fractured I can see through
the tooth it shouldn't be able to see
through the tooth it should be pretty
solid there might be an infection in
there eating away at the base of the
tooth and that tooth may need to come
out we've been searching for the reason
why he is not eating and that tooth
certainly could be it
you can't really force a 2 000 pound
animal to open his mouth if he doesn't
want to
so
we're gonna ask very nicely and hope
that he cooperates with us today
[Music]
okay here we go
yeah I wouldn't stick my hands in just
any manatee's mouth so I do trust Joe
much more than any other manatee
[Music]
I can easily move this for a smaller
back and forth with my finger
which Indians have it needs to come out
all of this treats last time I felt this
tooth it was not mobile like this so
this is different
oh did you take it out
you got it I think I got it
I said high five I don't have a hand to
spare it's awesome
ready let me have it give it to me and I
get some forceps
be awesome
I got it it's on my fingers I'm just
trying not to drop it don't let go don't
drop it when you take it out
oh wow
hey do you want to pull my tooth out wow
so I think it was just that one tooth
that was different trouble they're made
to lose their teeth frequently usually
they lose them on their own and you
don't need to go in and pull them out
okay this man she starts eating we are
throwing a party
good job Joe thank you
the next step is to get it back in the
water and see if he wants to eat it
should be very exciting
you can do a big guy
[Music]